WESLEY CHUN: Hi,
this is Wesley Chun,
Developer Advocate of Google.
They say the only constant
in the world is change,
and Google is no different.
And in fact, Google won't
exist without change.
So
[DRUM ROLL]
We're happy to announce that
the Launchpad Online video
series that you're familiar
with is branching out.
IDO GREEN: Yes, we are.
WESLEY CHUN: On the
Google API side,
we're creating a new series
called "The G Suite Dev Show"
where we'll continue to
show you a variety of things
you can do with the G Suite set
of APIs and developer tools.
Many upcoming videos will
be done in a similar style
as before, with code
samples and all.
But we'll also feature no-code
episodes like use cases
with multiple APIs, best
practices, common API features,
and special guests
from time to time.
Now, I'm happy to introduce
my friends, Alison and Ido,
to tell you more about the
other side of the house.
IDO GREEN: On the
Launchpad side,
the updated Launchpad
program is taking off,
focusing on making your
startup more successful.
As you know, Launchpad is Google
Developer's startup program.
Our goal is to help you,
developers and entrepreneurs,
through special
mentorship programs.
Even if you can't attend one
of our programs in person,
we will bring here a lot
of the useful solutions
that we learned about.
This series is
going to be focused
on startup best
practices that we
develop after
working with hundreds
of startups in the past years.
ALISON CARROLL: And if you're
in San Francisco, come visit us
at our new Launchpad
space where you
can get free technical training,
one-on-one mentoring, and more
education, all aimed at
driving your success.
IDO GREEN: Join us on
our YouTube channel,
and at
developers.google.com/startups.
WESLEY CHUN: Thanks, guys.
While our existing video
series is splitting up,
our goal is to further enhance
the overall Google Developer
experience, and we believe
that two is better than one.
Now we'll have a
pair of programs
to help you become
more successful.
Thanks for tuning in,
and we'll see you soon
on "The G Suite Dev Show" and--
IDO AND ALISON: See you
soon on the Launchpad.